oh hi Danny come on Ian looks like
you're having some trouble with addition
natural pee upset you're here to learn
and we learn from mistakes everybody
makes mistakes
nah-ah look at this question here what
is two plus two see you wrote 22 but
when we do addition we don't just put
the numbers next to each other that's
stupid
all right I think about it this way if I
have two markers in this hand and then I
add the two markers from this hand how
many markers do I have now 22 no Danny
it's four
[Music]
mrs. well we're Danny's parents oh yes
hello oh please please come in now don't
worry it is completely normal for kids
to get frustrated when they're
struggling with a subject so what's this
about Danny getting some answers wrong
on this so-called test of yours we had a
test one of the questions was what is
2+2
Danny answered 22 and and that's not the
right answer it says who says Matt are
you calling my son stupid no no of
course not who are you to say that your
answer is right and that his is wrong no
no no she's right thank you right out of
Nazi Germany you can't honestly tell me
that you don't know what two plus two
equals yeah it all figured out don't you
a smartass little [ __ ] what are you
some kind of [ __ ] all right I'm sorry
I am not gonna be able to continue this
conversation we're gonna complain to the
principal about you Danny is a free
thinker I'll have your job [ __ ] not if
you can't add two and two together you
won't
[Music]
mrs. Wilson oh sorry principal I didn't
see you I understand you had an issue
yesterday with the parents of one of our
students yeah did get a little crazy
when things get out of hand I really
need you to let me know about it
sure so how do you want to handle it I
guess you could apologize his mom hit me
I understand you told Danny he had a
wrong answer on his test he did have a
wrong answer on his test yeah it's not
our job to tell students when they're
right and wrong this is exactly what our
job is parents don't want you ramming
your biased views down their kids
throats
that's not biased that's how math works
you know it doesn't work your attitude
look maybe I can explain this in math
terms so you can understand if you took
all the kids in this classroom and
divided them by zero that's exactly the
amount of respect you're giving them
something you'd like to say you can't
divide a number by zero and get zero so
now I'm stupid just some crazy
administrator doing paperwork while you
superstar teachers change the world
[Music]
please have a seat mrs. wells thank you
you know I honestly think this will all
blow over if we just wait a week or so
I'm afraid we can't do that why not
they're suing for what the emotional
distress to a minor mess as well as can
you please tell the members of this
board exactly when you became aware of
this fiasco and the events leading up to
the Rowlett riot I just told a student
that two plus two equals four we need
for you to recant that what just say
that you're open to the possibility
there might be multiple correct answers
but that's not true we can't let them
bully us and this is so stupid stupid
that's your problem
anyone who disagrees with you is stupid
there is nothing to disagree with there
is only one correct answer for your sake
I certainly hope you have that correct
answer when the media gets wind of this
I do it's for I have my own answer this
school minus u equals tomorrow
you're firing me suspending while you
reconsider your extremist views you
brought this on yourself
[Music]
breaking news in what's being called
mass cake an activist elementary school
teacher was caught abusing her students
First Amendment right okay so this
teacher this liberal elitist tell this
innocent little first-grade kid that his
answer is wrong only her answer is
except yeah from what I hear she doesn't
even keep these students for more than a
year after that they all leave her and
go to another teacher
it's called graduating so it's creating
some good healthy debate in this country
some experts say that two plus two
equals four others say that it's 22 no
they don't
okay if you hate America that much why
don't you just go teach a commie France
hello for everyone's benefit how about
the kids
[Music]
[Music]
mrs. wells thank you so much for coming
you know I'm just so sorry it happened
this way if only you'd been willing to
be more open-minded about math what
about academic integrity you were warned
given an explanation
and yet you persisted but we will of
course fulfill our financial obligations
now that's $2,000 for your last pay
period in 2004 this one so that's $4,000
wrong its 22,000
[Music]
[Applause]
you know
[Music]
[Applause]